stephen brawl looking for his first win
got to see him be efficient out there
and there is room for one or two more
wild cards perhaps from that group
brought starts with a strikeout of
ending excellent 3-2 pitch dakota hudson
is 2.92 era anytime there's an era under
three i think you'll take it for sure
get up the middle there's the young and
there's a double play we move to the
second inning
cardinals got their first hit two
runners aboard
there's tommy edmund base head into
center field
ravelo being waved in
the throw to the plate is offline head
first slide and the cardinals have a one
nothing lead on a single by tommy edmond
one nothing cardinals
thank you so much brian reynolds for not
throwing the ball on the money here
i thought for sure they were going to
keep him
from trying to score
center fielder comes up with a good
throw i don't know if he's got any
chance of scoring but
hardest thing to do is throw the ball in
the money
cardinals are well aware
right of the bag out there
and out there double play
very nice play
so hudson came off the mound
that's chris conroy there's mike maddox
there on the left side of your screen
and
his knight is through gumberry is in
this game and we're gonna have to
let you know what is going on with
dakota hudson who went two innings gave
up just one hit
and walked a couple of batters it did
not give up any runs the first two
innings and only threw 26 pitches but
he's out of the game after two
stallings into right robelo is over
sidewall
and thumbs up apparently he's all right
but no ball
[Laughter]
this is a tough play down here
those short walls man they're dangerous
nice try though
just missed it
oh
two and two on polanco with two outs and
two on the pirates trail one nothing as
they bat in the bottom of the fourth
the two-two pitch
drive to right center field that ball's
hit well that's a line drive home run
for gregory polanco
a three-run line drive homer off gumber
in the fourth the pirates lead 3-1
my goodness
if that thing
gets hammered
i mean a missile that thing
did barely got off the ground i mean
and you could tell by the outfielder's
reaction that they didn't they had no
doubt it was going out of the ballpark
but this thing ended up a hanging
breaking ball well the pirates coming in
tied with cleveland with the longest
losing streak going on in baseball eight
games right now that one hit out toward
right this one's falling fast that's
down for extra bases
newman off to the races he's in the
score two out rbi double for stallings
pirates with a four run fourth
it's a nice area out there
collected that double that's where the
home run went
three straight two out hits six slow
curve ball
so now buck's on the pond for bell
nobody out
that's high and deep out to center
right so
bader
yeah every ball is going out that way
it's like a vacuum cleaner out there or
something
bell's got the rbi his 19th pirates have
another run five to one
ellage works out of the stretch
his pitch
a slider grounded to the right side
right field a base hit ravello up with
the ball they're trying to score the run
the throw home the tag got him at the
plate
reynolds is thrown out and the throw
down to second is not in time to get
newman
but the cardinals cut off a run at the
plate on a good throw by ronald revello
and the tag by yadi air molina well
maybe just maybe that'll get the
cardinals a little more amped up that
was a nice throw and actually good form
by ravelo too the ball was hit hard to
right field not a bad pitch but newman
took it the other way but rovello
charged that ball really hard i mean he
came in hard and came up throwing and it
was right on the money
goodbye
[Music]
stephen bralt with his first career
complete game
wow
striking out paul goldschmidt
well you never know what's going to come
next in baseball and for stephen brault
what a fantastic outing for him tonight
he was in command